alors michel serrault vous êtes beaucoup
moqué au début de votre carrière avec
jean poiret des interviews à la
télévision ça mettait le début de votre
carrière
donc vous allez payer ce soir on va
faire une interview nul on ne bouge pas
pendant le signale michel serrault
qu'est ce que tu veux est-ce que vous
préfériez hitler ou staline
je les ai pas aimé ni les uns ni visons
pas ce que j'ai préféré aller que c'est
un matin michel serrault vous devez
partir trois ans dans un vaisseau
spatial
oui avec quelqu'un oui vous préféré
partir avec fabrice luchini edouard baer
ou josé garcia à charbon mais pas vu
parce que les gens je les connais je
connais bien je vous avais beaucoup
maigri lui j'ai pas je le connais aussi
je vous intéresse edouard materis il
faut que je le personnage oui il faut il
faut qu'ils ce modèle il ya peu qu'il
n'est je pense que je peux le dire
encore des choses
les autistes et savent ce qu'ils ont à
faire tétreault mais lui berne on peut
encore travailler
vous connaissez d'ange blond donc oui on
allait me gnangnan sept ans blanc c'est
ce qu'elle amène des des consommations
non ça mon avis et des paquets cadeaux
pour l'unicef à ben ah bon
est-ce que vous préféreriez michel
serrault faire l'amour avec une fille
très laide très laide ou un mec très
beau je me barre oui je me bats
la boue
attention le mot de plus de cons en
amour est-ce que c'est merci encore
ou oui oui mais on sait ça va aller ces
sachets coup mais bon ça ma vraie jeu
teigne ça va c'était terrible c'est con
j'ai le mettre dans mon questionnaire ah
oui s'il vous plaît j'étoufferai
la bombe atomique arrive dans cinq
minutes enfin vous faites quoi quoi dans
les cinq minutes qui vous reste à vivre
je regarde ma montre jeudi j'ai plus de
4,3 avec qui passeriez-vous le plus
volontiers la nuit anne sinclair lors
sinclair ou brett sinclair elle prend la
1ère anne sinclair oui je la connais la
salle il fera plaisir
michel sait bien les enfants ils chance
oui allez y sont bien quand il chante je
suis son douzième à la
il s'en suit quel est l'animal qui
embrasse le mieux c'est montbrial a dit
non mais je vous dis simplement jeu
j'adore ce chien well as trois ans il
est beau comme tous les ans il ya une
chose qui n'a femmes se rendent pas
compte parce que dans ma femme dont je
parle même pas beaucoup je ne trompe pas
trop élevé mais elles sont pas très bien
compris ce qu'eux mais ça c'est autre
chose
moi quand je vois mon chien j'ai
l'impression de voir une personne est
alors il se dresse il a aussi grand que
moi il à la moustache comme non mais je
n'vous oui ça paraît rigolo comme ça
je vous dirai ce que tu veux manger je
veux dire est ce que tu crois qu'il peut
devenir un humain je crois qu'il faut
faut arrêter les pétards
il faut arrêter de fumer la moquette
michel à cette élection à la région aux
normes elles devaient faire attention
michel on est tous les deux oui on est
bloqué dans un chalet au tyrol
oui il a beaucoup neigé on ne peut pas
bouger du chalet oui on a rien à manger
ah je meurs de faim vous êtes obligé de
me manger vous commencez par quelles
parties de mon corps je crois que comme
commencerait parce que ça me paraît
elles sont assez belle et importante de
sa puissante frappe pas mal mal mal je
vais te manger les oreilles aux mamelles
du bananier vers spectacle en bas sur
l'oreiller oui c'est vrai qu'elle est à
votre avis michel serrault le sport le
plus con celui qu'on fait pas ah ah si
vous étiez en vente dans un sex shop
vous seriez quoi je pense qu'ils ont de
là dedans
j'ai la mémoire qui flanche je jouais
bien fait mais bien oui c'est vrai la
fuite patronat ugta et toi tu irais je
fais tiers des 100.000 solutions de
droite
ils ont peur en masse au maire mais
c'est le
non